so you uh become a musician
uh you have like an international
trip um you have this arc that spans
years
how did when was the first time you
started realizing wait a minute
like i'm not sure how fully i believe
these things
or that this is wrong or that there is
something
uh very dark and hateful that i may not
want to
continue to lead was there a particular
moment or revelation or relationship
i think i had doubts from the time i was
14 years old and that guy came up to me
in that alley
every day until the day i left eight
years later um but you know there
certainly were some moments that were
kind of like trajectory changers
absolutely um 19 years old i got married
uh to
you know another girl a girl who was 19
years old we had a child and then two
years later we had another child
so by the time i was 21 i had two kids
and i was a dad and a husband
that helped change me because my wife
wasn't involved in the movement
and when i was home i didn't want to
introduce my family to that she knew
and she you know begrudgingly you know
went along with it
but i also was a different person at
home so i had
kind of a replacement identity community
and purpose
and that was a massive help also around
1995 just before i left the movement
because i was trying to compromise with
my wife at the time she didn't want me
on the streets i decided
to open a record shop so to try and make
myself more legitimate
but i was selling racist music that i
was importing music that i was making
and but i was also selling hip hop and
punk rock and
you know black metal and stuff like that
it was called chaos records
uh so it was it was pretty evident that
we were intent on causing chaos
uh but the people i met there they knew
who who i was they knew what i was
selling and they were you know
customers who were black or brown or
jewish or gay
and they treated me like a human being
and and although it wasn't their
responsibility to do that and
i'm very grateful that they did though
they should you know they they didn't
have to do that
um that helped change me i received
compassion from people i didn't even
deserve it from and that was super
powerful you know it was 75 of my
revenue it was pre-internet so people
were coming in from all over the country
from canada to buy it i was one of the
only stores in america that was selling
that kind of music so
75 of your record store revenue was from
the
um white power racist music like racist
music
wow because i thought to myself that
that you had like a fairly normal record
store and then there were like some some
people who were getting
the the stuff like on the you know the
fly on the side but it sounds like that
was most of the revenue that's insane
well it was probably only 10 of my
inventory i didn't even keep it
out in the you know the shelves i kept
all the regular stuff out of the shelves
but
still the the racist music was 75
percent of my revenue even though it was
only 10
of my inventory uh
yeah so that was the business then i
mean clearly it's not like it's a normal
record store with like a
you know like a sideline i mean that
there's essentially a hate
music store no it was it was a hate
music store but then when i pulled that
because i became embarrassed to sell it
because of these new people i was
becoming friendly with
i pulled that music and of course i had
to close the store because i couldn't
even keep the doors open anymore
yeah so that that might have been the
big decision then when you like if you
make the decision to snuff out your
business i mean you have to know that's
happening
um my wife also left me
she left me at that same time my i hit
rock bottom is what happened i
closed the store my wife left me took
the kids um
and i used that opportunity in a very
sneaky and cowardly way
to walk away from the movement i didn't
denounce it i didn't tell
you know i told my buddies i'll be back
i just need to go work on my life
be back in a few months i was never
planning on going back
it took me about five years before i
kind of denounced it
and faced my past head-on i didn't
really start doing that until
you know 1999 or 2000 because i was
running
from i was really trying to run from who
i was as fast as i could
until i realized it was killing me to do
that so in your case
uh you went to college i want to say um
is that correct yeah i left the movement
96
took me a couple of years to really
figure out who i was i got kind of
depressed and then in 99
a friend of mine one of the few friends
i had at the time
encouraged me to go apply for a job at
ibm and i thought she was
crazy you know here i was the sex
skinhead full of tattoos i hadn't
i've been kicked out of like six high
schools one of them twice i didn't go to
college i didn't even own a computer at
the time manager and she's like yeah go
apply at ibm
it's a you know new position that they
offered like okay sure
and i went in and it was an entry-level
position it was
setting up um and kind of re re-imaging
all the computers that like a
corporation would
uh buy at once so be like 400 computers
and we'd spend a month you know setting
that up and my first job
was to install all the hundreds of
computers at my old high school
the one i'd gotten kicked out of twice
and they offered me the job and i took
it it was super entry level
and i was terrified because even though
they had no idea about my past
the first day of my first you know my
job out of the movement was
to go set up the computers at my old
high school and i thought i was going to
get fired and they'd you know destroy my
life
and i went i was terrified and uh you
know moral of the story ibm eventually
sent me
to to go to college but moral of the
story was
i met the man there that day on my first
day of work
who was the old security guard at my old
high school black man
who i whose life i had made hell and he
was the one who changed
my trajectory he's the one who you know
i didn't know what to say to him when i
came across him in the hallway i said
i'm sorry
his name's john holmes i said i'm sorry
mr holmes and he looked at me
kind of scared because i had made his
life hell when i had gone to that school
and he said
you know sorry makes you feel good it
doesn't do a whole lot for me
so i think you know you need to repair
the damage you've done and he embraced
me
this was a man i'd hurt a black guy who
you know in my heyday was
i made his life hell uh and he embraced
me and he said i
you know i believe in you and and i
think you need to tell your story and
that was in 1999
and i started telling my story in
roughly january of 2000
20 years ago changed my life he saved my
life i don't know that i would have made
it without him
well i'd say extraordinarily
compassionate of him
you know that we all like to hope that
we might react similarly to someone who
tormented us but
um most of us don't have that in us i
don't think
um so you're at ibm at this role and
then they say you know what you could
use some
some studies and so they ended up
helping you go to depaul is that right
yeah so i started out with this just
like computer installer and then i
worked my way up to
an assistant researcher or assistant
project manager and then i became an
assistant researcher and then
i got hired onto ibm full time uh
started to lead a team in their smb in
their small medium business division
when the internet was just picking up
steam
uh and uh through the work that i had
done had started like over 12
quarters um like had developed leads
that were like a quarter of a billion
dollars so
at that point ibm was was very happy
with with my work i had
developed kind of this pioneering
research team there uh
in the sales department so they were
like yeah you know we should really you
need a degree and i was like yeah i
would agree with that so i went and i
got my degree as an adult
in international relations in
international business
uh and i spent almost i think seven
years or
almost eight years at ibm and i got my
degree from depaul during that time too
and i'm really grateful for that
what an arc that must have been so that
takes you through a particular period
and
are you in touch with your um ex-wife
and kids
at that time um yeah uh
yeah yeah i never lost touch with with
my ex-wife and my kids
you know it was difficult with my
ex-wife when we went through the divorce
but i always wanted to be a good dad so
i
always always had the kids every weekend
you know friday to monday as they were
growing up so i never
lost that connection with them and in
fact they're 28 and 26 years old they're
not little boys anymore
uh and uh yeah so they're doing great
and
they saved my life too i mean it hadn't
been for them to really challenge me
and for me to have to be honest with
them about who i was
i don't know that i would have made it
this far so then
in 2000 you start telling your story
you're still working for ibm
how did that transition look no
eventually you wound up
writing these books uh starting these
organizations working in media
trying to get the word out um was that a
a big step i'm sure the first time you
started telling people openly about your
past that must have been very very
difficult
yeah i mean it really took i told very
very few people
like from 2000 to 2003 it was you know i
started to talk to family and people
that i knew
my wife who i'm you know been married to
now for for
you know 15 years i've known for almost
18 or 19 years
who also worked at ibm at the time it
wasn't until 2003 when i went to depaul
that i really started to tell my story
and then
in 2004 when my brother was murdered
that's when i really started to do the
work that i'm doing now when i started
to focus on trying to help people
disengage
from hate groups because i realized at
that point that i hadn't
that i could have been a better big
brother to him uh
and that now i could probably try and do
that with other people that i didn't
know
that also needed kind of a you know a
guiding voice
so to speak well we're certainly glad
that you did and
you ended up writing a memoir that that
was
published in multiple countries
and become an incredible figure thank
you
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know every time we have a new episode